Thinking back to what information we decided was important in the last quiz,
we're going to use that to create a word equation for the cost to make 92
glasses wipers. So try to remember which quantities we decided were relevant for
figuring out this problem, and then think about how those 2 quantities might be
related to each other. Place the letter of each quantity that you'd like to be
an equation in these teal boxes, one in each box of course. And then pick which
of these four operators you think relates the two of them together. Should they
be added, subtracted, divided or multiplied? Remember that what we're going for
in the end, we want this side of the equation to equal is the cost of
manufacturing 92 glasses wiper sets.